un reclamo cada vez más frecuente con
más de 120 bloqueos en Buenos Aires y
más de 20 en otras provincias los
movimientos sociales y sindicatos
expresan su descontento con las medidas
del gobierno para enfrentar el deterioro
económico que vivió Argentina las
medidas que está tomando el gobierno
creemos que va a empeorar la situación
porque va a haber un proceso que
profundizará la recesión al
priorizar el pago de la deuda es decir
al priorizar la especulación financiera
la pobreza en Argentina alcanza cerca
del 40% de la población según cifras
oficiales unas 18,6 millones de personas
tienen problemas para subsistir y los
precios continúan al alza con una
inflación anual del 102,5% en febrero
una de las tasas más altas del mundo
[Música]
por eso no es alimentar un pueblo es
quitarle la posibilidad de un
crecimiento sano casi 40 por ciento de
pobre millones de indigentes uno de cada
dos pibes con hambre es un desastre lo
que han hecho en este país este siendo
que la gente lo que necesita es trabajo
es necesita poder vivir tranquila y sin
embargo la están colocando en un terreno
de desesperación eso seguramente no va a
terminar bien durante algunos momentos
de la protesta los manifestantes
forcejearon con la policía Aunque nadie
resultó herido
los sindicatos piden que el gobierno
rompa con el fmi con el que acordó una
refinanciación de la deuda de más de 44
mil millones de dólares al tiempo que
convocaron a nuevas marchas para
mediados de mayo